everyone's eager to see writer director
matt reeves new take on the caped
crusader
and that hype only grew during dc fandom
on saturday august 22nd
2020 a new teaser trailer for the batman
dropped during fandom
and the footage made sure to note that
the film is currently in production
the batman is currently scheduled to hit
theaters in october 2021
but there's a chance that it may not
make that intended release date
meaning audiences might have to wait a
little longer to witness robert
pattinson's batman in action according
to reeves only about 25 percent of the
batman was filmed before the covet 19
crisis struck the world in the spring of
2020.
in an effort to curb the spread of the
virus film sets shut down across the
entire globe
and that included the batman reeves told
deadline in april 2020
a few weeks after production on the
batman shuttered we're not officially
editing right now
we've actually shot a quarter of the
movie and i've been pouring through
dailies
looking at takes and what's to come
after production on the batman was
halted
lead actor pattinson basically went off
the deep end while quarantined in london
issuing his workout routine and making
some pretty unsettling meals
all of which was detailed in a gq cover
story shot by the star himself
in the profile pattinson described
himself as quote
barely doing anything to prepare to jump
back into his role as the dark knight
which was
probably a joke probably
how about another joke mourinho i think
we've had enough of your jokes
thankfully the batman was just recently
given the green light to begin filming
again
there's no denying that's great news for
the production but it can't be ignored
that works supposed to take place in the
spring and summer months of 2020 has now
been pushed
several months to early fall warner
brothers did offer some breathing room
by delaying the film's release date from
june 25th
2021 to october 1st 2021.
still roughly 75 of the batman still
needs to be
shot and what fans saw of the movie in
its teaser trailer represents just a
small
portion of the movie it takes a long
time to complete filming and the batman
has a long stretch ahead
shooting may take a bit longer than
anticipated and post-production might
involve unforeseen reshoots
dialogue pickups or other edits that
necessitate more time spent on making
the movie perfect
therefore it's possible that with so
much left to shoot
the batman may cut it super close to its
intended october 2021 release date
or not make it there at all will that
four-month release date
delay be enough to make up for the
months-long production hiatus
all we can do is shine the bat signal
and keep our fingers crossed
given pattinson is in effect the poster
child for the batman
it's safe to say he's the biggest draw
to the gritty feature but he certainly
isn't the only one
the english actor is flanked by a
stellar cast that includes zoe kravitz
who plays selena kyle
better known as catwoman as kravitz
shared during the television critics
association winter press tour in january
2020
catwoman offers the perfect contrast to
batman which should make for an exciting
on-screen dynamic
she said selena kyle represents really
strong femininity
and i'm excited to dive into that batman
represents a very
kind of masculine power and catwoman
represents very feminine power
slightly more complicated and softer too
i like the idea that you can be soft
you can be gentle still be very powerful
and still be very dangerous
joining pattinson and kravitz are paul
dano as the riddler
jeffrey wright as james gordon the first
actor of color to play the gotham city
police department commissioner
colin farrell as the villainous oswald
oz cobblepot
andy serkis is alfred pennyworth the
wayne family's faithful butler
and bruce's most trusted confidant and
john taturo as mob boss and batman enemy
carmine falcone rounding out the cast
are two stars playing major figures in
gotham
peter sarsgaard as district attorney gil
coulson and jamie lawson as mayoral
candidate bella real
hopefully the batman will fly into
theaters on october 1st
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about
upcoming comic book movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you